good evening everybody
welcome to the developed committee 28th
of June 2018 first of all our usual
evacuation announcement should we be
required to evacuate the building would
you please leave the building Virant the
nearest available exit to the chamber
our assembly point is in the public
carpark at the side of the Civic suite
please don't delay your evacuation to
collect belongings please don't return
into the building and give them until
given permission to do so by a council
member a member of council staff please
note that the meeting is audio recorded
and if you have a mobile please turn it
off or to silent please item 1 our
apologies for absence that been received
from councillor mrs. Hoyt and counts
lamelle who is substituted by councillor
gooding that I can also covers to
substitute members has just said
councillor gooding non members attending
we've got councillor Lucas Gill minutes
of the meeting held on the 24th of May
2018 you happy for me to sign those that
as a correct and accurate record of that
meeting thank you item 5 declarations of
interest
they're with me I've just got a short
statement to read out for public record
items 7 & 8 relate to council officers
at 19 South Street Rochford members of
the development committee are being
asked to determine an application by
their own authority the matter of
members interests on the dual role for
some members who also sit on the
Investment Board and within the wyvern
project team has been considered ahead
of this application the monitoring
officer has considered whether members
of this committee have an interest in
any business of the authority such
members have a non-pecuniary interest
members of the investment board who are
making decisions to progress projects as
part of the council's policy to maximize
assets under the business plan may be
predisposed to consider an application
at the development committee in a
certain way however any decision taken
by the investment board does not take
into account material planning
considerations and does not show a
predetermination on the part of those
members therefore invite investment
board members that includes previous
investment board members present tonight
to disclose that they have a
non-pecuniary interest four members have
been on the project wyvern team your
role goes further as you have actively
participated in progressing the project
to the development committee it is the
objective of the project team to obtain
approval of the application and as such
it can be considered that you would be
predetermined for those members who are
present this evening please withdraw
from the chamber for this item you may
be allowed to listen to the officers
presentation and have five minutes to
speak if you so wish thank you
it's a Steptoe declared an opportunity
interest as chair of the investment
board Western I not only vessel now I
was there's a non-medical interest
that's a Williams okay Cassie honor
thank you as for Wilson number qu
interest as a member of the Investment
Board that's the hawk right number cuny
interest as a previous member of the
Investment Board that's a look scale
yeah mr. Gooding non-pecuniary interest
because I'm on the Investment Board
thank you okay thank you very much can I
just check that everybody has seen the
addendum which is an addendum to item 7
and 10 yeah everyone for that okay thank
you do understand that most of our
visitors are here for one of the later
items but there's a bit a few worries
about our fragile IT not coping with the
things not being in sequence in which
the loaded so we're going to have to
stick with the running order for this
evening so item 6 cherry orchard
brickworks cherry orchard way Rochford
so chairman members this application
relates to the site edge read here the
site is east of Cherry Orchard Way and
wraps around a row of terrace properties
on the western boundary the northern
boundary runs immediately adjacent to
the noble screen Brook and the southern
boundary runs immediately adjacent to
site to the south which already has
outlined Planning Commission as part of
the wider business park if I couldn't
take you to plan number two please yep
this is the proposals map for the joint
area action plan for the development
envisaged around the airport and
environs the application site is here
and is part of the allocation for a
high-quality Business Park and is
identified as area one on that
allocation these these two areas to the
south 2 & 3 are already subject to
outline planning permission can take you
to the existing site layout please the
site was historically in use as a Brit
works but no buildings associated with
this use remain when take you through a
few photographs these were taken some
time ago and different weather
conditions the this is looking south
so this is boarding that one's along
part of the western boundary of the site
and then Cherry Orchard Way is just off
to the right-hand side of the screen
here this is the row of Terrace cottages
that the site wraps around to the east
and then there's another part of the
site that just runs along a noble swim
brook just to that boundary there this
is an existing public right-of-way that
it's relevant to the application because
there is proposed some some monies
related to improvements to public
footpaths in the vicinity that might
include sort of upgrades and investment
in in this section never take you to the
next one this shows of this public
footpath then links the site quite
closely to an underpass axises is
currently closed but might be opened up
in the future with investments and that
then acts accesses the council's cherry
orchard own Country Park to the west
this is the actual site so this is the
row of Terrace cottages so this is
looking northwards to that elevation and
as you can see there are no existing
buildings on the site sites relatively
flat and some piles of rubble because
some of demolition has has occurred over
the years this is the side aisle at the
other side elevation of that row of
terraced properties and there is an
existing access point here you might see
just in the background and the next
photo I think I'm showing it more
clearly one of the next photos this is a
sort of substation that's just to the
rear of one of the terraced properties
they are proposing to sort of keep
something like that in the layout and
then this is within the site so this is
near to the northern boundary these
parts of rubble must have been sort of
demolished on the site and left there's
no active use on the site of the present
so this is the northern boundary
alongside the nobles Queen Brooke where
the site's drainage would go to again if
you can its adjacent to the Northeast
and some football playing fields
is that the last one Mike and then if we
can take you to the proposed site access
please so the application is an outline
application with all matters reserved
apart from vehicle access points to the
site so this is the site's southwestern
boundary which is immediately adjacent
to the site to the south granted
planning permission already as part of
this application to the south a new
roundabout access that is has already
been constructed on Cherry Orchard Way
what was built and then part of the main
access route through that site was part
of that outline permission that is
required to join up to the northern
boundary and provide an access point to
the site that we're discussing tonight
so there's two points of access to the
site of the south proposes this part in
this application and this existing
access point of Cherry Orchard Way would
remain but only to access the part of
the site that's going to be or the unit
that would be in the southwestern corner
Essex County Council highways Authority
are satisfied with the proposal in terms
of the two access points but do want the
main roundabout access to be the key
access and the kind of primary access to
the new Business Park
taken together so what they would
require by condition is that once this
access point was installed there would
be requirement to sort of close off of
this ability to run through that Road
point there if I can take you to the
illustrative master plan please as the
application is an outline with all
matters reserved apart from access all
other matters in terms of layout scale
landscaping or all matters that would be
determined at a later reserved matters
application stage but this plan is
provided just to give context and show
how the proposed development could be
accommodated within the site and how it
would link to the wider site to the
south if you could take you to the
illustrative site layout please
so whilst layout is not for
determination at the outline stage an
illustrative plan has nevertheless been
provided and officers have commented
back in the course of the application
and this is the third amendment to this
plan this has responded to some comments
by officers the open space within the
site has been more effectively
positioned within the site so that she
term would benefit potential users they
have included an access points to the
eastern boundary to enable future
development within this part of the area
one allocation which isn't part of the
same ownership or part of this proposal
to be accessed at a later date this is
important because we need to ensure that
the proposed development here doesn't
mean that we can't ensure that their
remainder of the applicant allocation is
able to be developed at a later date
also small changes to the layout have
been achieved
removing a sort of overly dominant
parking officers would however seek
further improvements to this layout if
it were to come forward as to reserve
matter stage in particular perhaps
increased separation form the rear
elevation of the Terrace properties to
this unit here we'd look for that to be
achieved and the breaking off of some of
the quite significantly large sways of
car parking with some greater degree of
landscaping but overall this layout is
not for members to determine tonight
it's just to show how the amount of
development could be accommodated within
the site this layout shows the proposal
for an attenuation Basin so there would
be some sustainable urban drainage
achieved there are several conditions
required from Essex County Council to
provide more detail of that by condition
the mix of uses however is for
determination in this outline
application and has changed in the
course of the application responding to
officer comments the mix now proposed is
predominantly B one office accommodation
which aligns with the vision of the
joint error action plan which is to
create a high quality business part for
the district with significant employment
opportunities the amount of B to more
German industrial or
and b8 has now actually not not reduced
it's completely eliminated so what
you've got before you is a proposal for
b1 office accommodation a small element
of d1 education which would be a nursery
facility a small amount of a3 cafe
restaurant d2 gymnasium and those
elements we as officers say are
ancillary to the main beef b1 use that's
proposed there are two significant
financial contributions that will be
required
the main one relating to the provision
of a bus service to the site and the
other relating to upgrading of the
existing cycle and walking network and
the applicant has agreed to both of
those in principle the recommendation
chairman is therefore one of Approval
subject to the legal agreement and
conditions as detailed in the officer
report all right Thank You Amberson I'll
start off on this as far as looking at
it is concerned the particular matters
that we're looking at over access i'm
tickler i think with the roundabout
already in place i think most people
have accepted that that that that is
something that can work the mix of use
matches what we're seeking to achieve in
our area action plan although it's not
to be to determine tonight i feel that
an informative should be added to help
when parking gets discussed at the
reserved matters stage I do note the
contribution to Essex County Council
towards butts bus service and
infrastructure enhancements we've talked
about cycleway and the walkway and so on
but I do feel that b1 office use is
going to attract a significant amount of
vehicle movements
we have maximum standards and I would
not seek to exceed those but I would
seek an informative in the in any
decision that we make that ensures that
the parking provision at least matches
that in the other half of the park so
that's just one small thing from me the
answer Steptoe thanks Jay just to put a
couple points of clarification if I may
please I'm not sure exactly where it is
on the diagram here on the plan but is
there a bridle way adjacent to this site
or is it on the other side of Cherry
Orchard way I'm not sure exactly where
it is first point
thank you now with regards to the brook
running along the I think was the
northern boundary and obviously where
the attenuation tanks will go in
obviously they will feed into that but
that's something to deal with the later
date what conditions are placed on it
for any work done on the site to prepare
it for that point to stop any
contamination into that brook because I
believe that runs straight into the
ropes I believe our mental health
colleagues are required the standard set
of control and contamination conditions
so they are all detailed in the
recommendation now so they would be
happy to submit details to us before
they started the development on the site
and then obviously there'd be also
licenses required with the Environment
Agency to drain into that brook at the
moment my understanding is there was
actually no drainage at the moment into
that brook but that would be their
intention for that ten uation pond and
the drainage to be capped at a certain
rate into that brook agreed with the
Environment Agency and Essex County as
well yeah that's the Western thank you
chairman I know you seen one of the
photographs you had a very high
telegraph pole on that site can you just
explain is that gonna be left there and
how will the are there plans to put all
the wiring for the electrics and
telephones under the ground as well
please they haven't provided details
with that in the application so clearly
in one of those photos and if we get it
back up but there are existing overheads
or cables the developer would have to
look at that but I don't think it's for
us to determine at the outline planning
stage they would have to deal with that
and deal with the companies as required
but it's they haven't provided details
at the moment
Thank You chairman the proposed bus
service will that be coming on to the
site itself or running along Cherry
Orchard Lane we dealt with the outline
planning application for the site to the
south and there are requirements in that
for bus stops within the site so take
you to the illustrative master plan
might show that best yeah so this is the
site to the South that benefits from
outline planning consent already and in
that we're set for to a condition
requiring two bus stops within that site
and on that basis the intention is for
the bus to actually come and loop
through the site but I don't I think the
County Council take the view that's the
walk from the bus stops within this site
would be adequate to serve the the
application site we're talking about
tonight so what we wouldn't require is
for the bus to enter the application
site tonight but it would definitely or
would seek it to come off Cherry Orchard
way and through the business park okay
thank you very much Williams Thank You
chairman and the small underpass that
you showed us I understand that that
used to be a railway alight railway for
the Brickfields is there any plans to
maintain that or the heritage of here at
least
the the underpass axis that was in the
photograph yes so there is a document
produced jointly by M South M Borough
Council Essex County Council signed up
to that as well and Rochford that looks
at the cycleway and pedestrian access
ways all around this area and linking to
watch the town centre as well and those
ambitions for upgrade and new public
footpaths around there opening up the
underpass axis is part of that proposal
and as part of this application this
outline permission we secured some
section 106 financial contribution again
tonight proportionately we're asking for
another contribution to that so there is
a pot of money available and I spoke to
my colleagues in planning policy they're
undertaking some work at the moment
looking at feasibility and who is going
to take that forward and looking at
opening up of that underpass but I
thought there's no firm dates for
exactly when works are going to happen
and I don't have any sort of plans to
show you exactly what that entails at
the moment just one question about
Health and Safety Executive raised an
issue about the site's former use and
about some aspects of its formal use
that may have a negative impact on on
the development have all of those issues
been dealt with been resolved so this
site because it had a historic consent
to store a certain type of gas required
consultation with Health and Safety
Executive but that consent effectively
has ceased because the brickwork site is
no longer operational but because that's
that it hasn't technically been
rescinded that that hazardous substance
consent the Health and Safety Executive
have required us to put on a condition
as it is in it at the end of the report
that means that they couldn't actually
build out and then occupy certain units
before
consent had actually been rescinded it's
the count's Rochford council is job to
go through that process of rescinding
that consent so we are in the process of
trying to ensure that that takes place
and once that's done it will be all
finalized but there is that condition to
protect things in the meantime on the
basis that because the consent still
technically exists there is still
technically the possibility of somebody
coming to the site and storing that
material even though it's very unlikely
that that would ever happen now
oh sorry thank you
yeah there's will that have any impact
on how quickly the site comes forward
and and will be developed we hope not
because they would this outline consent
is only the first element of the consent
so the applicant if they got outlined
planning permission tonight would still
have to go through a process of
submitting reserved matters applications
and we are in the process well I with my
colleagues and legal have already sort
of started that process of making sure
that that hazardous substance consent no
longer exists at the site so we are
hopeful that it wouldn't hold things up
for the developer and that's why we've
sort of started the ball rolling okay
thank you
members we have a recommendation
starting on 6.33 going through to 6.44
which I'm happy to move from the chair
with your agreement also adding an
informative about the parking provision
at least being equal to that in the
other half of the side those members in
favor of that please indicate any games
no notice everyone that's Karen thank
you
item 719 south street Rochford change of
use to flats I was taking this one mr.
Evans
this is one way there is some additional
information on the addendum
Thank You chairman good evening members
so the application is in respect of the
change of use from the current office
used to see through use comprising in
number eight flats which are comprising
seven two-person one-bedroom flats and
one three-person two-bedroom flat so the
location I think we're all familiar with
the site it's it's located to the east
of South Street in the Rochford
Conservation Area so it's likely out
plan here so this is the existing site
layouts so basically what the plan shows
is as the report indicates there are 10
currently TennCare parking spaces within
the rear courtyard area serving the site
the site area does extend to an area of
garden at the rear so this area will be
retained basically and the report also
indicates that the current parking
provision is a 2.4 by 4 point 8 meter
parking space which doesn't comply with
the current standards however it's a
change of use and therefore the
justification placed forward by the
applicant is that in terms of
intensification of use as that isn't the
case that the current parking is
actually sort of adequate if we move on
to the next slide please
and what that slide shows is there's a
slight there is a slight alteration to
the parking provision in that an area at
the rear of the site will be extended
slightly to create a turning area here
with
the existing pave their ribbon increased
by approximately just over a meter just
to provide a little bit more space but
basically that's the site layout so it
is as per existing but there's a
notional red line here which earmarks an
area of amenity space that can be used
in connection with the proposed use okay
I think yeah there's some forces like to
show possible
we'll just run run through a few
photographs that little ol make sense
obviously that's the frontage very nice
three-story building brick building
simple architecture of its period
looking across from South Street I'd
like to show that assess next if
possible please yeah there we go so
that's the site access which is a narrow
access it's a gated access we have a the
next slide shows the actual gate that's
in place that's a view up the street so
that is the current gated entrance
because of the listing there's no
intention to change that arrangements
it's very much fixed by the fit by the
fabric of the building and I just like
to show a few photographs as we progress
through the site so the building on the
left is like the outhouse this house
house on the plan is going to be used
for cycle storage for refuse storage and
also general storage so I think what the
scheme demonstrates actually is the sort
of effective use of buildings those
having to add anything to provide the
basic provisions to support the
residential use and move forward again
please there we go so that is a view up
the carpark looking up towards the rear
garden area so it's a very much
established brick paving area and as the
report says in terms of the the drainage
on site that remain unchanged it's a
permeable surface there we go so that is
the alternative view looking down the
actual courtyard arrangements down
towards the rear of the building members
will not from the report that in terms
the alteration
to the building this application really
tests the principle of the the change of
use and whether there are any issues in
association of that change of use that
are objectionable whereby the the
concurrent application for the listed
building consent deals more with the
alterations or the physical effect of
the works on the interest of the
building however as its listed the the
listing element is also an overriding
material consideration within the
planning application and therefore hence
why there's a duplication on the on the
detail provide in the reports they
reciprocate one another but that's in
accordance with guidance that we have to
apply but what I'd like to just sure and
refer to within this photograph is the
the rear porch area that's very much a
modern addition in connection with this
developments that rear porch area will
be taken away in order to provide more
light the rear of the building very much
in modern addition and it's not a sickly
desirable elements of the scheme we can
move on thank you and that's just
another view of the site so what we have
is we've got the main house and also
we've got a two-story you've got the
three storey elements at the front and
then we've got this two-story element
filtering down to a single story
elements which is this building here so
these will all be flats and I just like
to run you through the the floor space
and the for the flats there we go
so the ground floor plan what we have
effectively here is flat one flat one
here so flat one is a thirty-eight
square meter
flat flat two they're all sort of
double-bedded bedrooms effectively flats
who is a forty point four square meter
flat flat three which is in the two
storey elements here is a forty one
point nine square meter duplex
arrangement and flat four here is
seventy seven point two
meter squared and we've just move on
quickly to the first floor arrangement
first floor flat five sorry flats five
there we go on the first floor that's
flat five isn't it flat five is a thirty
nine point five square meter that'll be
a two-bedroom unit and flat six isn't
great
flat six is a forty six point one square
meter then we move on to the second
floor which is flat seven similar
arrangement here hmm it's okay flat
seven which is the third floor room is a
forty point one square meter and flat
eight is a forty one point one is forty
eight point one square meters so the
issues really we'll move on to that
essentially this application as I've
alluded to tests and assess is the
principle of the use and it's
acceptability whereas the concurrent
listed building consent application
considers the impact of the use on the
fabric of the building so just to sort
of conclude on those key considerations
in terms of the principle of these what
the report actually highlights is is
that policy H one of the core strategy
indicates an appropriate level of
residential intensification within town
centers and also concentrates on the
efficient use of land and that is
aligned with the key principles of the
national planning policy framework in
terms of reducing pressure development
pressure for residential use in
Greenbelt so the application highlights
where the actual proposal meets with
those policies interestingly then also
within the report the the actual use it
south would be akin to a thirty units
per hectare density which is considered
to be efficient use of land I think what
the report actually sort of tries to
sort of focus upon a
there is no presumption against the use
members will not the comments received
from the Economic Development Department
in terms of the requirement for space
with in Rockville town center for to
promote up-and-coming businesses and
that was taken into account however
there is no policy which would override
the presumption in favor of sustainable
developments to which the authority
considers that this scheme is it's a
sustainable town center location reusing
a heritage as a set in doing so in an
appropriate manner the impact of the use
members will not the actual gated
entrance there's there is no change that
entrance in any way there is no
objection from the highway authority and
there's no intensification of use the
parking members are not from the reports
point 6.57 there's a 91% provision of
the parking provision aligned with the
current standards now it's short
basically of one visitor space of seven
flats require one parking space the to
bed flat requires two parking spaces and
there's also requirements of North Point
five parking spaces per flat so there's
a shortfall actually in real terms of
one parking space which is a visitor
parking space which is the not point two
five x four to make the one parking
space so the the arguments and the case
put forward within the application is
it's a sustainable tongue sensor
location where policy does indicate that
there is an allowance given the
sustainability of a site there is an
acceptance of a lowered standard
providing there are good accesses to to
services and that's the basis on which
the authority consider the application
just to clause in terms of trees on the
site plan a couple of trees t1 and t2
will be removed to create the additional
turning area at the top of the site
members will note from the addendum that
we have now received their response from
the a Baruch cultural advisor who has
issue in relation to the application
that they are trees of of no significant
importance that's the the sites there's
not evidence of breeding bats on site
however members will not from the
conditions that there are conditions I
think it's eleven and twelve in terms of
safeguarding bats one including a
lighting scheme the manatee space is
provided within the rear area so that
there's a requirement for amenity space
of 25 square meters per flat also
members will note from the reports that
the application cites the availability
of further amenity space granted across
the road near the lake and just to
conclude then just to lead us back to
the revised recommendation members will
note from the attendant that's a couple
of Corrections if you like have to be
made the one was in relation to the
scheme not being able to comply with a
packing standard so as an oversight on
my part in terms of applying the the
modern standards so that's been amended
in condition four and condition five in
terms of the gates it suggested now
chair that the gates will be maintained
in an open position so the current
status cause maintained just to conclude
then in terms of the parking provision
highways have got no issue and in terms
of the the short full of one parking
space commensurate with the current
standards I think what my report
actually concludes is that that in
itself does not amount to a reason to
refuse the application in that there'll
be them and demonstrable ham so highways
safety and on how you were parking as a
result of that shortfall therefore chair
it's my recommendation given the revised
recommendation that approve will be
granted thank you want to say anything
before we get started on this one
okay thank you that's a step toe you
stinking [ __ ] I'm concerned about the
entrance is it possible have two
photographs back up in with the entrance
from the website don't worry if you
can't
might take a while and start talking ok
basic basically what I'm a little bit
concerned about is if those goats are
closed and people are trying to get into
this site it could mean a vehicle has to
stop covering the footpath to get into
the site so I'd like to perhaps see if
the gates are going to be closed tonight
condition 5 but if there is the option
secured in position and maintained as
such in perpetuity
yeah that's fairly comprehensive sorry
and the other concern I had was with
regards to the people exiting from the
site as you're coming out to the site
there's you have to come across the part
of the foot pathway and see if anybody's
walking along is it possible to have
some sort of mirror perhaps there so you
just get a glance of people coming down
for Papa okay that's the Westerner Thank
You chairman and sorry said obviously
did you just did you mention the I
notice uncovered those photographs for
the trees and the foliage up layer is
obviously because it's summer at the
moment it quite extended are the trees
being either cut back or being taken
away if they're just being cut back
whose responsibility is it afterwards to
look after the trees and the foliage
their place okay that's the good ink
also information comes don't play that
thank you Kevin
I understand currently that at the back
of the the property
it's all open access all the way back
behind the council offices as well is
there any intention to have that secured
off so that the site is contained or or
where that still be open access to for
those people who are resident in the
flats to access about thank you and I'll
just add one given the sensitivity of
the site the potential narrowness of the
pavement and they'll clearly be a
management company that looks after bits
and pieces they're probably including
the trees accounts the Western mentioned
but in the past we've known management
companies come and go in this particular
location even things like putting the
bins out need to have a degree of
control because the street is narrow
it's on a prominent location it's next
it's a heritage building it itself it's
next to a very important heritage
building so I wonder if you could say
something about the strength or the way
in which the management we can have
confidence in the management company and
the way it work thank you oh sorry let's
gather all together kennel first of all
apologies I should have also declared an
interest at the start as a member of the
investment will go into this yeah
but that can be noted and I could still
speak just concerns about the amendment
to the access about the gates being open
all the time
is there any mitigations against parking
abuse in those scenarios especially if
the residents are required to pay for
those spaces as part of their rent
I've noted five main issues that have
emerged one question was about the Niren
the the access now in terms of the
acceptability of the access so at a
point set back 2.4 from the edge of the
carriageway one would have to look at
the visibility in each direction and
we've got I think the previous
photographs will show the actual
visibility from the access that's the
one that's the visibility looking down
south street so in terms of a mirror
we're familiar with the issues of
mirrors I think the general feeling
about mirrors are that if you have to
install mirror opposite and access that
is almost tantamount to saying that or
acknowledging that the access is
substandard but nearer x' don't always
seem to work really so in terms of
addressing that issue the highway
response really does set the bar in
terms of what is acceptable so given
given that there's no intensification of
use per se in in in terms of in relation
to the office use so if there was an
intensification of use there was more
cars that would then raise the issue
about the adequacy of the visibility and
a setback visibility but because there's
no intensification of use that
consideration as a material
consideration doesn't really come into
play that would be my opinion so
although I appreciate what what you're
indicating might be the use for the
mirror mirrors are basically tantamount
to accepting an unacceptable situation
in the first place so we have to take on
board what hi you is a saying and it has
got no objection but it does lead us on
to the issue about the gates
hence in terms of human nature what the
councilors mentioning here in terms of
it will be open it has to be remain open
because obviously for the gates with
there's an issue then with with piling
back onto the road etc that would be a
dangerous situation so in terms of those
gates remaining open with a conditioner
suggested in the amended condition 5
that to be retained in an open position
at all times it retains the current
status core effectively there was the
other issue about the landscaping
there's a condition on landscaping so in
terms of crops like to refer the issue
of the development management company
over but in terms of the the landscaping
there's a condition there on the
landscaping so in terms of the trees you
use the councillor asked about what's
going to be trimmed back so there are
two trees going to be trimmed back in
the area where there's going to be an
additional turning area at the top of
the site so but there's no other sort of
trimming back effectively is gonna be
more enhancements within that rear
garden area there was an issue raised in
terms of the access and the open access
through the site through the courtyard
so indeed one could walk from the gated
entrance through the courted area to the
rear garden area not also through two
mill view court and it's acknowledged
that there is open access although the
residents of Millview court use the site
and utilize the site but we have to
remember as if we could prefer right
back to the site layout plan aged in red
what we have to remember is the extent
of this Planning Unit actually only
extends to about one third of the total
land area of the rear garden so in terms
of how the rear garden area in its
entirety is used by people at Mill view
called that will be remain unaffected so
to address the question there'll be no
sort of physical barriers per se erected
within that rear garden air
it's just a notional red line that shows
the the provision of the 25 square
meters per flat ratio in the Rio garden
area so there's one more question I
understand which was that in terms of a
development management company could I
perhaps refer that over to yourself
because I'm not aware of the
arrangements Thank You chairman just
briefly members will say that normally
when we have the bigger schemes that
there are hundreds of houses there's
quite often a lot of open space area
that isn't publicly adopted so the
management schemes that you normally see
negotiated through 106 are for the
upkeep of those places which I think
these days the residents collectively
pain so I'm not aware of any of those
who actually manage the site by taking
bins out the best comparison I have is
your development similar to this that we
do that acacia house in East Street I
think there was six or nine flats
something like that there and there is a
similar at the rear of the building
there is a building with the bins in it
those I think are either collected by
the operatives or that the householders
put them out like all other householders
do I think for the purposes the bin
collection chairman it's a matter of
scale if you've got a very big scheme
then there may be some management but
then the management schemes that we
normally discuss at this committee
really cover the large areas of open
space that require upkeep exactly are
they going to put them on the highway on
the path out in the front where the
watchword is or Jim in the case of that
case your house I think they stay in the
shed and the operatives collect them but
the the bins store here and if I will
can show it on just show it on that you
use the laser yeah they're not that far
from the collection point so the the
freighter pulls up for a few minutes
gets the bins emptied and then after a
few seconds he's moving away there's not
too much of it I'd like yes
seconds or so while they open and shut
them and put them back but they they
normally allow for it some of the
operatives they had bigger bins so
instead of empty and lots of multitude
means they have say one for recycling
one for non Recycling's etc so they they
two of them push out a big bin and then
that's it that's the job done it doesn't
say in acacia house where there's a real
bottleneck it doesn't cause a problem
Thank You chairman you're just going
back to just following up on the
question that I raised before just for
clarity you say that the the rear green
space behind the council offices are
already open to the public so is that
whole area open to public use if there
is their actual right of public access
to to the rear area or is it just for
residents of the of the other right just
to clarify that so although I said that
physically one would be able to walk
from South Street through the site I
think it's fair to say that the by
virtue of the period of use of this rear
garden area by the people courts they've
assumed a right to use it and in
previous representations on a previous
application the views had been expressed
that it's their garden but the
applicants has actually confirmed that
there's no actual legal rights for them
to use any of that space but they've
assumed that right to use it so it's not
effectively it's not actually public
open space it's just space that is
associated with the rear of 19 South
Street formally in a in a in a in a
bygone era was agricultural land at some
point which became part of a curtilage
which by now by virtuous use is seen as
something that that
is available for the use of people of
mildew courts but no they have no legal
right to use it follow up on the parking
abuse question I'm not sure I
necessarily agree that there's no change
I think my understanding is that it's
only open at the moment during business
hours and they are now proposing it open
24/7 and also those base on allocated to
certain people's use whereas I believe
that would now be the case in these
proposals I think they would then ask
the question again should we mitigate
are there any plans to mitigate against
parking abuse in this area
I think the answer's no to that one
effectively members we've had a
discussion on this we've got a
recommendation printed on page seven
point three six through to pay seven
point three nine with two revised
recommendations around point four and
point five those members in favor of
this proposal please indicate those
against that item is carried item eight
we cover a similar ground but out of
necessity nineteen South Street Rochford
thank you
right so this is a concurrent
application and it basically as the
report indicator deals solely with those
issues in terms of how these the works
or the use affects the fabric of the
building so just to start off briefly
with the statutes the main statutes that
govern the consideration this
application is the list of buildings and
conservations areas Act and the National
Planning policy framework chapter twelve
conserving and enhancing historic
environment the reporting section 2.2
cites the alterations essentially what
the report indicates is that during the
1980 substantial works were undertaken
to this building which entails that
there is very little if any of the
original fabric left internally however
the external shall with the exception of
heavy windows which are our replacements
the only original fabric the building
probably is the actual outer brick skin
itself and the internals of masonry
other than that the house has
experienced extensive renovations I'll
just sort of refer to a few things on
here the the actual works themselves or
just indicates very briefly what they
are so this works obviously that will be
required to make this building fit for
purpose for residential use mainly
complying with Building Regulations the
they'll be elements that'll be repaired
and enhanced and as I've mentioned the
rear porch of removed so internally the
building is devoid of any original
features that's indicated in sections
who point to the report section two
point three sites how in the 1980s
interior walls floors ceilings and
joinery almost completely replaced
leaving very little of the original
fabric so in summary what are the works
proposed then in connection with the use
which is those works that this
application is to consider there's going
to be acoustic installation insulation
new partition walls and openings but
reusing many of the existing openings
windows and external doors will be
refurbished replacement doors and window
procured to match the existing style to
slim double-glazing
restating of the outbuilding ceiling
joists and upper floors raised to allow
for higher Headroom floor joists which
are non original strength and then
replaced so it's pretty much basically
an internal refit really the externally
I think it's important in terms of
listed buildings section 2.8 of the
report says only flues and bathroom
vents will penetrate the external walls
kept to the east and north elevation
because obviously because of the the
type of use there'll be obviously tumble
dryers washing machines bathrooms w
cease operating on a on a 24-hour basis
so there is going to be moisture in in
the in the building so that doesn't need
to be hard to have an outlet basically
for that so if we just move on quickly
then in terms of the key provision
within the within the actual statutes
themselves is the legislation in Section
66 and 72 of the 1990 Act and it's
basically the requirements and local
planning authorities not to as such
preserve buildings but to take special
interest to account in the event of
change of uses and the the report in
Section 6.5 all actually indicates that
it's a positive impact because the the
background to the various legislation is
that it recognizes that buildings have
to adapt they have to change given a
certain use because sometimes buildings
will fall into disrepair so therefore
buildings have to be able to be
adaptable where possible and I think
that where this application there isn't
any issue from a listed buildings point
of view is because the building has
experienced so much extensive renovation
in 1980s there is very little of the
fabric left I'm not sure we can show
that internal you know I did have a
couple of internal photographs but what
the photographs would show us is in the
unable to bring the photograph up I
apologize but in the downstairs corridor
what one will see
when they look into 19 so Street is
you've got modern lighting you've got
the fire alarms
you've got attic ceilings one would not
be able to other than the stairs itself
which is a relatively ordinary stairs
leading up from the front door there is
nothing about the building that would
tell you internally that it's of any
historico interest whatsoever no exposed
beams nor to the nooks and crannies so
in terms of the actual legislation and
preserving and taking into account the
special interest of the building other
than potential works in terms of flus
and vents which I believe is consisten
dish 'end in accordance with the Essex
play services historic buildings advice
they're satisfied that the works are
acceptable and there are conditions in
condition three of the of the proposed
approval for listed building consent
which provides some safeguards in in
approving details such as the 1 in 20
scale sections of windows so I think in
terms of achieving a sash type window
what's the authority would not want to
approve in the light of the legislation
is windows that would be an appropriate
for that shell of a building so slimline
highly efficient windows that are in
keeping with the general architecture of
the building
therefore chairman bissette is my
recommendation that listed building
consent be approved as a separate
approval from the planning application
thank you okay members we have a
recommendation printed on 8.17 came
through to eight-point 18 those members
in favor of the approval please indicate
thank you that's unanimously approved
just waiting for counselor on our turf
get back there we go
so item 932 Park Gardens Hawk well
proposed rear extension this isn't
normally one that would come to us but
there's a potential conflict of interest
so it's proper that we see it in front
of committee this is strength Thank You
chairman this application as chairman
said related to a member of the staff
and it's this shallow that you see on
the southern side of Park Gardens omits
several other chalets that are on this
side
typically Park Gardens has got a number
of pitch through front dormice very much
in vogue with your guidance modest
dormer cheeks modest good scale the
attractive dormer Styles there are a few
flat roof ones but even those are modest
in scale if we can go to the existing
plan please Katie the existing building
has those dormers like I just described
you'll see again with modest pitched
roof styles it is some development at
the back which doesn't primarily concern
us tonight and if you best way of
looking at this application is even to
put a roof plans you see the two dorm as
the central ridge line across another
smaller door at the back and a small
flat roof inconspicuous dormice at the
back if we can see the proposed plan
three please chairman and sorry Katie
the proposal is to link those two pitch
through front doors rather contrary to
you know if this application order came
in you'd try and encourage them to do
what they they had is the simplest way
of looking at it and you'll see that
they then link up over the roof ridge
into the dormer at the back
there there is no appreciable increase
in height it's roughly equal to the
ridge but just slightly above it best
seen on the roof planner gain that we
saw earlier on instead of isolated
pockets of dormer forms in the roof we
see this large bulky flat roof addition
basically detracting from that character
and given the presence of other Dorman's
in the street he really officers feel it
lacks the sky land character and
sympathy that your policies and guidance
would normally follow so the
recommendation Chairman is refusal for
this one for the reason that's set out
in the report
do it
I said as ward councillor I'll declare
non-pecuniary interesting I've got the
western man yes you're the officer of
these is this two properties of one
property and can I have and can I look
at a photo of the maybe of the street of
the properties have you got one up there
please we don't have that picture
Sherman we don't have photographs of
this one or an aerial view but to answer
the question you'll see usual style with
these they draw a dotted line down that
side it's a semi-detached property and
so what you see on the drawing is the
one unit as you would say it's one half
of a semi-detached pet Thank You members
and there's a recommendation for refusal
printed on page nine point four those
members in favor of the refusal please
indicate those against
that item is refused thank you item
number 10 application referred from the
weekly list land adjacent centuries the
[ __ ] Hong Lankan Udom Thank You
chairman this application is located on
the eastern side of Pudsey whole line
patil farm further off the drawing there
to the north you'll see that the site is
edge bred it's a smaller part of the
actual ownership of the applicant the
remaining land in blue demonstrates that
the applicant has control over that land
but it's not part of the application
before you and whilst we're on this plan
there is a couple of sort of a mobile
home and a touring caravan on there
they've been on there a number of years
those two caravans there are not part of
the application that you're going to be
considering tonight the site is in the
Greenbelt and within the coastal
protection belt and this application is
part retrospective for a traveller site
the application relates to the front as
I've explained and if we can see the
site plan please the proposal sa the
area read now in better detail you'll
see is this sort of rectangular shape to
the front with the access onto pubsey
hall line the application is part
retrospective boundary fencing has been
put up to about a height of 6 foot 2
meters and 1.8 meters or so with gates
to the front large part of this area all
hard surfaced in chippings and hard core
for which there's an enforcement notice
been served and then a gated access to
the land at the back which we understand
from the applicant he intends to if
successful have for grazing what is on
the site at present is a mobile home
across this way and up here and what
this equates to in traveler site turns
chairman is one pitch a pitch sorry two
pitches a pitch comprises a mobile home
a static permanent base and one touring
caravan that is either hitched to a
truck and goes on touring or some of the
self-drive motor home
structures this application is including
a day room but on site at present that
day room has not been constructed the
applicants have found a assess poll on
the site which we saw at the beginning
the week they have connected to an
assess poll is if you like it's a tank
in the ground there's no biodegrading
it's like a box if you like and when
it's full it follows to be emptied if we
could see one of the photos is there's a
chance please the ones facing into the
site three hopefully this will show
members what the appearance of the site
has I've just described no Joey
yeah if you can open that yeah
it's fear with it there you go chairman
that the this this side is the northern
side to a Pudsey farm that is the
entrance onto puzzie whole lane and
you'll see there's the surface that's
been put down and this is what we would
call a static or mobile home type more
permanent base they're all they're all
mobile that these tend to be more fixed
to the ground and have slightly more
permanence the tore up that I referred
to there that's parked on that site
there it's more easily transported I
think we could go back to the site plan
please and enforcement notice was served
this application was retrospective and
when those works run the why now with
the applicants submitting a plan for you
to consider tonight that enforcement
notice has time to take effect until the
27th of July to allow members to make a
decision tonight and then that has it
depending which way members go there is
then a further three month period for
compliance now in terms of the overall
analysis the development proposed
whether temporary or permanent is in
appropriate development in the Greenbelt
government policy and the advice from
government on travelers and gypsy sites
is clear the the subject to the best
interest of any children on the site
personal stank circumstances an unmet
need are usually unlikely to outweigh
the harm to the Greenbelt again clear
advice and a clear position the National
Planning policy for traveler sites
requires that when making decisions
account needs to be taken of the
criteria listed for you in paragraph 28
OE and I draw members attention to which
the level of local provision and the
availability and lack of alternative
accommodation for the applicants is one
of the criteria together with the Part
II which says there doesn't need to be a
local connection of the applicant to the
area members may appreciate the previous
advice I think from 2006 required
applicants to demonstrate some
connectivity to local area the current
policy does not require that
I had hoped to show members the
allocation but if that's not great if
you can please the members will be aware
that there is a site allocation in your
allocations documents at Mitchell Inns
farm now that has been adopted since
2014 and we don't have a planning
approval the site has not been developed
and laid out ready and there are a
number of difficulties with developing
that site it's part of a wider
application alongside some industrial
and commercial developments but it would
meet the current requirement for 15
pitches which is changing in the
emerging of ice to 19 pitches here we
see it the is part of a wider allocation
for commercial development and this site
here is the hectare or so for the
allocation that you have now there are a
number of problems with that the site is
generally been subject to contamination
and action that the council has taken in
the past there is been ownership changes
which haven't helped bring in the site
forward and there is also difficulties
and constraints with the railway line
bridge here the highway authority when
looking at this when you when you leave
this site you need to accelerate away
particularly if you're towing say
caravans or using HTV vehicles you need
a certain amount of ability to merge
into the flowing traffic now that is
constrained here by the railway bridge
that goes over the what is now the
eighth 12:45 so there are difficulties
in in achieving the allocation that we
have now whilst it's clear from national
policy that a failing of like this
should not normally outweigh the harm to
the Greenbelt the difficulty we have
with this site is that the council's
land that it would use to move this
allocation is all in the green belt the
green belt boundary is very tightly
drawn to the existing settlement which
means future allocations and provision
largely are going to be met from
Greenville allocation somewhere and this
is what has been tested by two planning
inspectors one unexciting watery Lane
which was slightly different to this in
that involve some previously
land on a former pumping station but
still in the green belt and that
application was retrospective like this
it was it didn't have planning
permission first members considered that
application alongside some enforcement
action permission was refused and a
appeal inspector granted approval a
permanent permission for [ __ ] sites it
wasn't personal in she made the decision
in November 2017 and then more recently
we've had a grant of permission for a
non retrospective site an applicant put
in a case obviously the the Raley club
in ha bridge road and not joining a
house called Woodville some members may
remember it was also a site proposed
some time ago for peaceful place for a
dementia respite care and the applicant
there had unlike this applicant had not
done anything retrospectively they put
in a planning application we refused it
because of the national policy and the
fact that it was green belt and in
February this year 2018 an inspector
granted permission this time on a
five-year basis and made it personal to
the applicants who proposed so you've
got two slightly different decisions but
what they have in common is that both
inspectors reasoned that as a vast
majority of the district is designated
Greenbelt with the exception of fairness
Island which is separately controlled
and not easily accessible to the
traveling community to find sites that
there for future allocations and [ __ ]
site provision is going to be met from
what is currently Greenbelt somewhere
and that presumption rather undermines
the stance in the national policy that
group that gypsy and traveler sites
should not impressions be located on
green belt they should be located
elsewhere in Rochford x' case other than
what is already developed and anything
that may come forward by why i've
previously developed land then future
allocations will be met
the Greenbelt now in the earlier
decision for water align the inspector
was critical that no provision was being
released through the development plan
reasons I've explained to you earlier
how the allocation so far hasn't been
successful and therefore provision would
likely happen through ad hoc Planning
Commission's like this one that we have
here planning applications like this and
the one that was then before her and
that the council could not demonstrate a
five year supply of deliverable sites or
longer-term sites over six to ten years
in broad locations in the whole Ridge
Road decision the inspector noted that
some 17 pitches are currently
unauthorized in the district which
reflects the demand that is between that
sort of the 15 pitches under the current
allocation and 19 by 2033 in the
emerging gypsy and traveler assessment
that you have the inspector gave
significant weight to the absence of the
five-year supply and a failure of local
policy and unmet need and a failing to
meet that need in future now this is
perhaps particularly pertinent that
inspector was struck by the contrast in
success between the allocations for the
settled community that are bringing
sites forward like you've seen in Hall
Road applications in outline on whole
bridge development in detail in white
cream etc and the contrast to the lack
of provision and the effectiveness of
the allocation we have at Mitchell ins
farm for the traveller site the findings
are both expect as a material to the
current application you have the
circumstances around this application
before you tonight are very similar and
if you like it's been rehearsed not once
but twice by two previous inspectors in
the last sort of 12 months or so the
circumstances around that provision of
deliverability have not changed in
officers view there hasn't been a grant
of perhaps an outline permission on a
site somewhere to release a site and the
likelihood of that coming forward and
therefore that situation with the
inspectors decision is what has framed
the recommendation from offices
for a five-year period now you'll see on
the addendum chairman that there are
comments from canoeing parish council
and a trust that members have read the
read those and I don't need to go over
those so the recommendation chairman is
for approval for a period of five years
and personal to the applicants largely
based on the whole bridge road
application and for the other conditions
as you're see set out in your report
you've got mr. Thomas who's going to
speak on this one
[Music]
five minutes I'll let you know when
you've got a minute to go
my name is mr. Thomas mr. Stan Thomas to
make certain snowed about there's
another Thomas in the council DA another
to do with me
I have lived at four st. therese of
Pudsey who lane for over 40 years it is
my last property and they'll is the last
brother Lane party before the fuelling
farm and closest to the application site
the area's changed it over the last
year's and is open quiet and peaceful
I'm opposed to the planning application
because the introduction of house
service and five structures in into in a
previously open area will seriously
harmed are being built for personal
experience I'm aware that the harm to
the Greenbelt is treated very important
issue by the council and the planning
expected development is only allowed in
Greenville under exceptional
circumstances can this be exceptional
recently I was applied for a single for
a single bungalow honest and for my
severely disabled daughter on land I own
which is adjacent to the site in
question notwithstanding the fact that
sure is a special allocation for that
for disabled people my application was
refused and circumstances cannot be
considers exceptional if you can see
where how my daughter walks you would
understand what exceptional could
possibly be possibly approaching death
the National Planning policy framework
requires local authorities to plan for a
mixed housing including for people with
disabilities the lack of a visioning
Rochford did not stop my application
being turned down I understand the local
authorities also required to provide
travelers pitches Raj predictors has
done not has done has not done this and
so has once filed against to provide the
specific type of accommodation however
it seems to be the case in this
application there are no ditches
no no pitches available available that
means permission it could be granted
from my point of view there seems we
seem to be very unfair
not only does the not only does it
appear unfair my application for a
single bungalow would have been far less
impact on the green belt land a huge
hard surface and five structures the
officers report on the application
states that paragraph 23 it is
considered that the development would
clearly have an adverse effect on the
green belt openness and that clearly
constitutes an encroachment on the
campus side I produced several I
produced an aerial photograph showing
the site existing and the site proposed
this shows how truly and above the
estate Mazar demonstrates at once a
total Greenbelt becoming something akin
to an industrial estate this must surely
be considered by anybody to be
unacceptable in this particular location
the planning officer then goes on to
justify his recommendations of approval
of the application by citing two
reasonable sites where the travellers
pitches were allowed in green bill I've
read both these decisions than know they
differ in many ways that and I've been
both these in the decision and note that
they differ in many ways from the
situation in puzzle Lane I feel that
they set a precedent to justify justify
disapproval firstly both those
applications relate to sites that are
considered to be suitable for standing
it by planning applicant inspectors
watery Lane site is within a walking
distance of whole bridge and it's many
facilities always wrote is is on a bus
route and the inspector described it as
accessible to services party hall Lane
is remote and not accessible by bus and
is unaccepted opted Road is unsuitable
for increased traffic
secondly both sites have boundaries
which are already well screened by
Achuar trees this makes them far less
visible whether public viewing the
application of the site in nature in is
in nature open the application is
opening is safe in nature and planning
under Allah takes trees mysterious that
take stablishment it's just a minute to
go the policy of this explained was the
HR planning travel sites say the council
should be strictly limited to travellers
in sites open and country that can be
away from existing sentence they appear
to the appeal appears to be refer to the
company policy the application does not
does not just please no does not I also
know that the ad decisions the
conditions in which the prevent
commercial activities are taking place
on the site including the storage of
materials parking of vehicles over three
and a half tonnes and reservation limits
external lighting why I know such
conditions attached to this
recommendation of approval I fear that
the Commission would be should be
granted I feel that sure this permission
be granted the holder sort will be used
as an intensive fashion leading complete
destruction of peace and Frank would at
the other area the council has got as as
clear grounds upon which to refuse this
application it does not knows not
impractical pair with either the planet
besides this is if this planning approve
with the council sending a clear message
that all travellers men and a legal
activation of Greenbelt learners carried
out in proportion become acceptable
thank you thank you
ten seconds ten seconds leeway I gave
you right you wish to say anything
cancel Lucas kill can't say Oh No
before my class but chairman firstly
like I think the offices much thankful
for a constructive argument with full
regards to our decease position and also
mr. Thomas's concerns on a puzzling
whole line this report I and I had to
think about it for a few days and also
listening to these speaker and and the
officer before the committee is a
marginal case and in terms of very
special circumstances I find this very
worrying recommendation and seemed to be
largely based on fact that Rochford
district counts does not have a five
year supply of traveler pitches which
makes it likely that any appeal against
a refusal of planning permission is
likely to succeed saying that this is
really unacceptable and should be
addressed as a matter of urgency as part
of our debate this evening before any
appeals are lost by a watch for district
council my view is that the site should
be identified through the local plan
process and not in ad-hoc way as it is
currently happening having reviewed the
report and the concerns of the residents
and the parish council as the ward
member are considered that the
development is unsuitable to the
Greenbelt and coastal protection built
and special lens landscape area I think
for my opinion clarification is required
from the environmental authority on how
to deal with the human and other waste
on site in interest of Health and Safety
I Polly support the comments by the
residents who have submitted their
objection in this report a few of them
like
us starting development prior to making
the application the damage to trees and
shrubs and hedges lack of action by our
RDC to defend the Greenbelt and
inappropriate Greenbelt development and
out keeping with development area and
out of character with local area
character this is only a few and I could
rattle on a few more which will take me
hours on end I don't think you would
want me to do that to ceiling because I
rather get on with the debate saying
that our development plan has been found
to be sound fit for purpose and as
delicated aside as not only green belt
but a landscape improvement area but as
an aside the site has had these
allocation as mentioned in reports
namely the 1838 the 17 118 and the 17
180 that's all I've got to say at this
stage because I would like to be
involved in the bait and ask the
Chairman to come back as a summary after
the debate that's the Western
Thank You chairman I noticed on page 219
and you have said that it's only
temporary permission for five years and
if and when the dependents or the
children leave the site then everything
has to come off the site my question is
if after five years the if this is
approved after five years the applicants
do not come from the site does that mean
to say that we are going to have to do
another enforcement notice and the other
thing is how are you going to oh how are
we going to monitor that no more than
two one static one mobile home is one
mobile home is going to be on the site
itself and can I have a photograph if
you've got one of the area of the you
haven't got one okay thank you cheering
chairman because this is a retrospective
application and maybe I confuse matters
in my presentation but it's only partly
implemented at the moment so when I lay
but there was two statics and one turret
and we was able to see some photographs
of that this application before you is
for what you see on the plan so it would
be two mode two statics and the more
permanent mobile homes then they're not
impermanent in law because it takes 24
hours and they can be towed away
but the larger more fixed to the ground
they have they have jacks and ramps they
have proposed gas connected for heating
etc they're distinct from the touring
caravans which can have similar
connections like like the caravan cup
you know the tow it you have your water
and things connected but the idea is
that the gypsies travel they have a
settled base which is taken by the
moment by their the statics and then
they use the tourists but for going off
touring so what is proposed before you
tonight is effectively two pitches a tip
a pitch qualifies as a mobile home with
a
and what you have here is two mobile
homes and two tourists but they would
share a day room so if you granted
planning permission this is the
development that would have permission
it's only partly implemented on site at
the moment because the applicant has
stopped works as a result of work by our
councils enforcement team and the extent
of hard standing was stopped because
there was a stop notice so but we had to
be mindful in the way we manage that and
the government would expect us to be
reasonable and measured in our approach
that having stopped somebody albeit that
it was unauthorized that we'd be
reasonable in a period of compliance so
we've give them an opportunity in the
way that the enforcement notice is
structured for this operation to be
considered by you tonight and then
depending on your decision things will
cascade now to answer that the question
it's pretty easy to monitor the site as
to how many are there it's probably
nothing anybody can do to stop extra
caravans and vehicles being brought on
to the site but then you might say in
law there's nothing to stop somebody
murdering somebody what happens is the
consequences of the action that you take
if you like illegally yeah and in this
case if you say that you know no more
than two mobile homes and two tourists
and a third fourth turret turns up
likely chances that the council's
enforcement officer would visit the
applicants and point out to them they
don't have permission for those extra
caravans that's happened on other sites
and what we found in some of those cases
they have visiting family and friends
there might be a wedding or a funeral or
something in temporary temporarily
somebody is there for say a long weekend
but if it has permanent looks like
they're looking to say take advantage
annexed intensify the site then they'd
have to either make a planning
application or we'd have to take
enforcement action we'd have to consider
that and we'd see see where that goes
I think that was the question about
monitoring chairman if I've covered that
I think yeah
oh yes after after five years then
obviously the permission would lapse but
we don't know we haven't got a crystal
ball as to where we will be with a local
plan allocation now what the way the
officers recommendation is framed is
that if you imagine when you when you
specify a temporary time period you've
got to have a date in mind as to why
you've chosen say five years seven years
three years whatever you'd rather in
sort of just pick a date to hand there
has to be a reason justification behind
it now in the case of hull Bridge Road
the inspector felt that it would take
five years to get a allocation perhaps
through your emerging local plan and
then that site would have to get
planning permission and then be built so
he's allowed in his estimation a period
of five years to achieve that now what
would happen here is that when the five
years if that's what members decide is
granted their permission would lapse but
these people have agents and what they
normally recommend is if there's no
chance of the council having provided a
site or a site being available as an
alternative they might then make a new
application to renew that consent or
just putting another application - - but
up to it in timescales and then you
would be able to consider that as and
when and in the circumstances that arise
that's clear thank you chair um just one
for the officers if RDC do get a
permanent travel site within the five
years will mr. meeseeks I cannot be
given six months to get remove
themselves off the site to the permanent
site and then put all it back to how it
is now and could we will the residents
on the site as is now be named so we
know exactly who is on that site
and I saw the concerns of finding that
no other travelers will actually be
living in it thank you take councillor
Goodings question as well
Thank You chair but I was just
interested to know with the dayroom what
materials would that be would that be a
permanent fixture the building because
it does have a pitched roof so that if
that is passed that would be a permanent
feature Chairman yes it's a brick
building and tiled similar to AP's or
the large garage in size you see them
actually on holiday campsites you know
there's like evolution's blocks that you
have it would be a building like that
it's quite usual on gypsies I don't know
some members remember when we went to
the site near Colchester United and some
members may have been on that trip and
that the pitch had each pitch had a base
static iturra
and then it's owned a room on the site
in terms of naming the occupants it is
possible if you like with the applicants
consent to detail who is on the site we
currently the council's enforcement
officer has reasonable contact with the
applicants the problem you have in the
Gypsy community sometimes is they know
the Sun follows the father's name
follows it so if you take a pacific name
you almost like you've got to say you'll
see in the inspectors decisions where
they have aged the person but you could
you'll see that the condition that we've
recommended to you is one of the suspend
ones that the Planning Inspectorate News
and what they have covered is that it be
used by the applicant and his wife who
are named there but the important bit is
their resident dependents because what
can happen is that the Gypsy community
they may have a relatives say a parent
or grandparent come and live with them
because of illness or something like
that and and then if you're not careful
that person although they need to be
resident there
they wouldn't be lawful to it and you
there'd be questions as to why you need
to name everybody so precisely rather
than as the planning spectra do where
they say we'll look miss that if you
like the parent applicants then there's
the dependence what you can really
control is the number of caravans which
is perhaps more more specific yes thank
you chairman I'm looking at the planes
and I'm looking at the plans on here
either side of that pitch is I noticed
one size probably just Lane with nothing
on it but what on the other side you've
got like those two yellows they how
these buildings are what exactly are
they next to these site please
a local thatching local Thatcher that's
been around a number of years unless he
sold the site but there are agricultural
burdens there barns and sheds and it's
my belief that what he does on the on
the local farm land he uses the old
machinery the binders that sort of drawn
agricultural machines that cut wheat
into sheaves for thatch in a modern
combine harvester can't do that and he's
been based there a number of years but
given that he's been there a number of
years I don't know if he is now retired
but that was definitely his base when I
was a kid mr. Wilson thanks Chad there's
a couple of points I'd like to ask one
is about paragraph 37 the cesspit and
also condition seven it was that the
presumably that cesspit was in existence
before the people occupied the site it's
the first part question and just that is
that suspect connected to any other
property and then following on fire
what's the distance to the nearest
inhabited property because you mentioned
the two buildings there are farm
buildings what's the actual physical
distance thank you that's the whole page
you want to make your point place
Thank You chairman yes I just wanted to
ask the officer if this application is
refused therefore it goes back to
enforcement I'll take it and that
enforcement would look to remove all
occupation of the site in due course is
that correct
chairman dealing with the last first the
enforcement notice that is on the site
and stop notice is currently against the
hard standing because at the time that
the development began those were the
works that were in place what since
happened as obviously the mobile homes
have come onto the site now depending on
your decision tonight if you were to
refuse the application it would be then
logical to serve an enforcement notice
against the the activity that's on the
site notice without had repaired and
served okay it's not unusual that as in
the case of the watery Lane site that we
talked about that the owner then say
well I'm bored the land I'm committed to
the land I'm already moved on they then
appeal they challenge your enforcement
notice and one of the grounds 'is that
permission should be granted there are
other grounds about the reason of us
have compliance and things but the the
one to be mindful of is that if you like
the Planning argument
and that's why those two decisions that
I've mentioned in my presentation a
significant one of them was against
enforcement notice the water in lane one
is against enforcement notice under what
we call ground a but there's also a
sister planning application alongside
that but bad enforcement notice would
seek the cessation of the unauthorized
use depending on your reasoning notice
has to be backed up by reasoning and we
would seek that from you in the decision
if that's the way that you go in terms
of the the cesspool I've seen it it's
roughly located about here and the
applicant has rather discovered it
because he's he's been on site I think
he's been using it for a week or more
but it was there it seems the history of
this site that previous owner used it
for many many years is some kind of
leisure use and they've particularly
used this part of the site but we
understand that there may have been a
caravan maybe thirty years ago down this
this corner it's only here saying what
some of the locals I believe have said
but it's likely that that cesspool is
there because of that Caravan now the
council's drainage engineer has tipped
trace dye into the into the tank we did
we did that on Monday and he will see if
it percolates out or where it may come
but we without excavating everywhere
like an ologies archaeologist and trying
to find where it goes we don't know if
there are other connections what's
currently connected to the site is the
tomb of our homes and the tour prior to
that the applicant had the portal is
like you see in events or on building
sites
thank you I'll come back to you to sum
up before we go to a vote in it in a
moment I look at this application and
read through the the various issues that
have been raised and listen to the the
speaker that we've had and I have a
great deal of empathy with the the
points that are made however as chairman
of the committee I need to deal with the
factual elements of it and the reality
is this counsel does not have
alternative sites available we have the
principle of them outlined in our core
strategy but the likelihood of them
being delivered within five years is
slim at this moment in time and there
are issues around the site and it's
deliverability anyway we have two recent
inspector decisions they've been closely
argued independently viewed and on both
occasions the decisions have gone
against us I believe that our training
the decisions the status of our core
strategy does force our hand on this one
and I think that the approval that is
suggested is the only viable way forward
with us this evening but members you've
all had a opportunity to speak counsel
you all know you asked to come back and
I'll let you do that before we have a
vote so there's a quick question it's
more of a quick statement
thank you for summing up I'll take a
slightly different view in respect that
I view the protection of green belt
probably as a higher priority there
seems to be a number of variations and
differences in this particular site to
other previous examples and I think it
may be fair and I think there's probably
good reason to say that if this does get
taken to a government inspector the
council could be seen to be doing so
taking the decision of
refusing this as a reasonable course of
action and therefore we could the the
inspector may take a different view than
what has happened previously so we could
potentially not be putting a council at
risk and we may get a decision slightly
different from what we've had before
anything's possible
chairman think for it for will allow me
to come back after listening to the
debate and also the officer in question
I'd like to put a motion to the table
which I'll be seeking support from the
planning officer in the amendment of the
recommendation is formally formally put
together the first point the planning
permission should be granted for a
temporary five years the reason I'm
saying that is based on the other
inspector decisions which have been made
on our other sites and also the points
raised by our officer that a temporary
five years is granted point to this is
underpinned by section 106 legal
argument we stipulates that in the event
that an authorized travellers site
becomes available within again five
years period the occupier vacates the
site within a period to be agreed point
three in addition the occupy agrees to
submit a landscaping scheme which I
mentioned earlier in my original
discuss speech earlier to ensure that
the site is returned to its original
condition point four and this is where I
would seek a recommendation from the
officer now in the event that the
illegal agreement is not signed within a
certain period of a certain period we
could say six weeks a month two months
from the date of this resolution to
grant planning permission the
enforcement team today take or I should
say the Thorson team can take the
appropriate action now I've made notes
here based off the discussions and your
sum up some summary chairman and I
believe this may be a way forward rather
than proving the way forward by
approving the planning but with the
amount with these amendments attached to
it okay IRA members before I can ask you
to take any sort of decision on these we
need clarity over them so further the
first item was about five five-year
temporary permission that's already in
the recommendation I believe that the
item about landscaping is adequately
covered as set as item six within the
proposed approval for site details of
landscaping roads landscaping
so that leaves us with the three items
106 vacation of the site enforcement
timescale could you just say what you
were saying you want to go on 106 bit
chairman if I may the section 106 to
limit the occupies you'll see there is
it sorry chairman you'll see that the
requirement of the section 106 advocated
by members to make it personal and that
they vacate the site you'll see that is
covered by condition 2 now firstly what
should happen is you either cover it by
an agreement if that's what you prefer
or a condition rather and duplicate both
that's that's something that the
government is very vexed about you do it
by one or two means you don't bet on
belt braces but what their advice is
also if it can be done by a condition
then that should be the preferred route
but it's members choice as to whether
they rather than deal with it under
condition - or sorry no conditions
condition 3 about the clearance of the
site if they prefer it to be a legal
agreement you'd have to strike out
condition 3 that when the land ceases
and the duration that's a choice that
you have now the second point about
signing an agreement in six weeks I'm
sure my colleagues at the end of the
bench had a shock there I believe the
fastest legal agreement ever was dealt
with in two months some of them take two
years average wise and Becks would
correct me if I'm wrong I think is that
about six nine months something like
that you have to get people to sign
draft them etc and if I have a little
dig the way solicitors work
I think if members are of a mindset that
they want to agreement fast and signed
and completed nothing was ever signed
legally that it worked well in heist and
I think there should be a reasonable
time far more greater than say six weeks
I think you should look for a longer
period of time because at the end of the
day that that may be
challenged and you want to go possibly
for a judge or somebody over this that
would then say well why'd you know six
weeks is an awful long awful short time
rather to complete a legal matter of
complexity like this so I'd advise you
to think of a longer term than than six
weeks and so maybe my colleagues would
help me with that and that then brings
us on to the enforcement team taking
action if the agreement isn't signed
you remember that the enforcement
operation works on expediency if in
accordance with government advice and
rules that it is reasonable for them to
take that action clearly local people
and others see breach as a green belt as
reasoning enough and that may be the
sentiment of this committee right now
but you have to go in a more measured
measured right and and to come in hard
like that if it's challenged by the
applicant as the council he could argue
is being unreasonable in being so quick
and forcing this you could end up either
in possibly in a court possibly before a
government inspector so I would just say
a more measured approach is the way that
it works I don't know if my legal
colleagues want to concur with that or
whether they want to to disregard - to
offer an alternative chap what I will
say is that in terms of 106 certainly
they are usually as I'm sure this
committee will be aware dealing with
matters in terms of infrastructure to
make the development more acceptable in
terms of this matter you're seeking to
limit the the time scale which already
appears to be done by way of the
condition I'm not sure that a 106 is
actually the appropriate mechanism in
this case and would concur that a
condition set out already would be the
more appropriate manner to deal with
this I am aware dealing with temporary
permissions which this is the section
dealing with that does give or also an
indication that
should be for a specified period well
than one that would be adjusted under
the the 106 as you're suggesting so that
does give me and some concern that
reason I don't feel that it'd be the
appropriate course of action to take
certainly when the condition is there I
would concur timescales on 106 is can be
dependent on a lot of external factors
it wouldn't be possible for me to give
you a timescale as to how long it would
take to complete an agreement thank you
I think given the officer's advice what
I'll do is um I'll move the approval
from the chair as stated and printed for
members to either support or not as the
case may be if members choose not to
support then they'll need to be another
vote on another motion put forward with
with the terms so we've had a detailed
argument we've had the detail and it's
been quite a technical discussion those
members in favor of the approval as
printed on page 10 point 19 please
indicate to those against
motion for approval is rejected I
therefore invite a member of the
committee to put forward an alternative
proposal
he caught me on the hop but you caught
me on the hop the planning permission
which we've granted for temporary five
five years and I appreciate its in in
the document itself but I think it needs
to be stated or or Clara stated within
recommendations herself
sorry sorry oh now I agree with what the
legal teams are said about the 106 but I
still feel strongly that we should
actually stipulate a five-year period
that the occupier vacates the the site
within a given period to be agreed now I
asked my learner gentlemen college for
some report here from from their own
experience but I'm also I agree that the
landscape and skiing yes it it is within
the report but the sign as a first and
also to protect our DC going forward for
other sites I still believe that we
should actually put a legal agreement
together to ensure that in six weeks is
nonsense to be recommended by the legal
team in whether from the date of this
resolution and to ensure that the again
would be something to decide whether the
enforcement team will take the
appropriate action if if that is not a
hereby
okay counselor mind accounts the hook
way comes in at this point
Thank You chairman I wasn't I didn't
understand that there's a specific
proposal within that don't know if I'm
wrong no normally what happens in these
circumstances is it's the flip side of
the coin that is the way for well III
can I can perhaps maybe simplify the
matter by providing a proposal I propose
the the application is refused on the
grounds of inappropriate development in
Greenbelt do you have a seconder for
that how's the shore second that okay
thank you
okay okay right members we now have an
alternative motion for refusal has been
performed and seconded on on so it terms
of the impact on the Greenbelt those
members in favor of the refusal please
indicate
those against
thank you that item is refused thank you
very much for your time and attendance
this evening